and now I'd like to introduce our first
speaker after the break rob davis from
columbia university he's going to speak
to the theory and printer practice to
cool and the implementation of
meaningful collaborative collection
development so take it away round I'm
delighted to have this opportunity to
speak to you this morning on the complex
enterprise with the goofy sounding name
to COO my brief observations are based
on two years in the two cool trenches as
librarian for Slovak Eurasian and east
european studies at both columbia and
cornell what is too cool well if you
haven't done so already I would
encourage you to take a moment and visit
the two cool website at two cool dot org
because it lays out in detail the
objectives in general areas addressed by
the two cool partnership I think you'll
find that while to cool maybe radical in
a university library context much of
what it seeks to implement is anchored
in good old common sense it seeks
efficiencies in all areas of library
operations across two campuses via
topic-specific studies conducted by ten
different committees chaired by cornell
and columbia library staff can we find
better ways to leverage our human and
fiscal assets are there ways we can
integrate cataloging ease resource
management and digital preservation
activities can we streamline
acquisitions and processing of new
materials by making procedures more
uniform across the two campuses are
there ways in which we might together
pursue joint licensing arrangements with
vendors can we improve upon the
game-changing borrow direct interlibrary
loans
system by further shortening campus to
campus delivery times can we implement
reciprocal on-site borrowing privileges
for faculty and students are their
research resources that we can acquire
together that we're unable to obtain
acting alone and what are the various
legal technical fiduciary and governance
issues that we must consider in such a
partnership these are some of the broad
issues being investigated and in many
ways being acted upon by to cool with
the generous support of the Andrew W
mellon Foundation and in partnership
with Ithaca with a que snr research from
my perspective as a librarian involved
principally with the acquisition of
materials the most innovative
transformative element of to cool
concerns the way collections are being
developed and serviced to cool seeks to
coordinate foreign language collection
development across two institutions
avoiding duplication and in so doing
create a unified collection of far
greater breadth and depth than could be
accomplished by either institution alone
to cool is also a radical departure from
tradition in the area of reference and
research support exploring a variety of
collection specific service models these
are the two principal aspects of to cool
with which I've become intimately
familiar and upon which I will focus my
remarks now my particular world area
encompasses a great swath of global real
estate stretching from Siberia through
the former Soviet Central Asia the
Caucasus the Balkans East Central Europe
the Baltic States and of course the vast
Russian Republic I'm responsible for
collections in 28 major languages and
probably another 60 minority languages
of the
former Soviet Union now when I entered
this field now a quarter century ago
collection development was a remarkably
predictable perhaps even a little bit
boring exercise you had a network of
state-run book chambers you made your
selections off a state publish lists of
soon to appear books you then conveyed
your selections to one of a handful of
western book dealers officially licensed
by the Soviet government larger
libraries had approval plans with these
dealers and they would do the bulk of
the selecting for you based on your
collection profile publishing was
heavily subsidized so the state so
prices were dirt cheap the most
interesting non-commercial materials
came via exchange relations with
literally hundreds of academic
institutions throughout Eastern Europe
and Central Asia a single North American
University Press monograph priced in
hard currency brought you a boatload of
such interesting publications under such
circumstances there was little incentive
for american libraries to work
cooperatively who cared if Princeton
Columbia and nypl had the same Russian
title on shelf as institutions were
often competing against one another for
federal support of their area studies
collections a Cold War missile gap
mentality crept into our collective
consciousness consciousness and
sometimes volume seemed to trump quality
to be sure there was discussion of
cooperation and efforts such as the rlg
conspectus to see who was collecting
what were undertaken but little done to
truly coordinate and collaborate
certainly none of the co-operative
collection development ish ative 'he's
had any teeth or procedures to monitor
compliance and to be fair this was all
pre borrowed erect
pre scanning and traditional I ll was a
bit clunky since the political collapse
of Eastern Europe the life of the Slavic
and East European library specialists
has become much more complex centralized
book publishing collection and
distribution systems imploded gifts and
exchanges departments went the way of
the dodo and besides the partners on the
other end began to want cash not
subscriptions to Scientific American the
old system was gradually replaced by a
huge network of in country and out of
country vendors each newly independent
country developed a vibrant publishing
scene generating far more material than
before the fall of communism as for
pricing say goodbye monopoly money hello
euro for some and currency
convertibility for all across the board
prices throughout the region are now
comparable to the Western market
shipping costs once heavily subsidized
by communist governments have
skyrocketed and for many of the region's
I deal with can be as much as a third of
the value of the books themselves in
short while these geopolitical and
economic changes have undeniably been
for the good for those of us who collect
such materials in the West they have
significantly eroded our buying power
and made acquisition routines far more
complex on top of all this add the
expense of a growing number of area
specific database products as well as
the plethora of demands placed on
library budgets generally clearly we
cannot as individual institutions do
justice to what is available one can
therefore understand why someone in my
position would be so eager to embrace a
project like too cool alas
not everyone in my field sees it that
way I was the meeting of other East
Coast Slovak librarians up at Dartmouth
College right around the time of the
first formal to cool announcement a
colleague from another library now
retired publicly predicted that to cool
would sound the death knell of Slovak
librarianship and that I was holding the
dirty shovel beside beside the gravesite
following the actual implementation of
to cool Slavic in the fall of 2010 I was
attending the annual Slavic and east
european studies conference in Boston
and was bombarded by library colleagues
with questions some reported not
surprisingly that their administration's
were keenly interested in the progress
of the project most were simply curious
about the what and how of the process
some were downright hostile in a very ad
hominem way the names Quisling Judas
Benedict Arnold were murdered by some
one longtime colleague wished me good
luck but I hope for our sake you fail
she said with two years of to cool and
practice behind me I can assure you that
to cool is not the number of the beast
it is not assured in the apocalyptic end
time for Slovak librarianship quite the
opposite in my humble opinion it is
ushering in a renaissance by
significantly broadening and deepening
the range of materials available to
audiences in Ithaca NYC and via bar
direct and traditional I ll far beyond
at a time when other institutions have
dramatically in in some cases
indiscriminately slashed acquisition and
staffing in general and for foreign
language collections in particular bold
new initiatives aimed at expanding the
research resource base need to be
embraced not shunned I've discussed now
the why let's turn to the how of
implementing to cool
slovak as we started the process we
wrestled with two core questions could
collection development be successfully
coordinated at these historic
collections across a number of languages
avoiding duplication while maintaining
relevance and utility to the mix of
faculty and students at both
universities and perhaps most
controversially could one individual me
satisfy the reference and research needs
of two campuses that are four hours
apart we approach these issues very
carefully embarking on a lengthy period
of self study and then gradual
implementation which may be divided into
seven over often overlapping phases
phase one the collections columbia and
cornell slavic and east european
collections are among the largest and
most historic in the West their combined
Russian holdings and taking into account
overlap of the third largest in North
America behind only Harvard and LC both
have substantial acquisitions budgets
before we discuss specific models for
collaborative work in the Slavic area we
gathered and analyzed data on both
collections as they stood in the winter
of 2009-2010 historic strengths
weaknesses approval vendors use serial
subscriptions existing collection
profiles etc we looked at data for both
the too-cool partners and Beyond in the
borrowed direct universe for the sake of
comparison so we had a solid
understanding where we intersect and
could effectively collaborate phase two
faculty involvement this phase I think
was ultimately the linchpin to the
overall ultimate success of to cool
Slavic we began by surveying and
assessing current faculty and curricular
needs on
with campuses based on faculty profiles
at both institutions the next step was
to travel to Ithaca and conduct a series
of one-on-one meetings with faculty
needless to say when I arrived on campus
uh I encountered a high degree of
skepticism Cornell's longtime Slavic and
east european bibliography had retired
the previous summer in the midst of a
hiring freeze the impact of both
endowment declines and reduction in
state aid cornellà courses a hybrid
private public university had already
impacted programs across campus our
conversations were taking place during
some of the darkest days of the
recession so faculty were expecting the
worst in our discussions I explained
that this was not a pretext or a prelude
to acquisitions budget cutting and that
yes Weill Cornell would be losing an
on-site presence that that I would be
responsive and helpful to their concerns
and research needs I think that these
conversations helped to assuage some of
their concerns and minimally enable them
to put a name to a face such as it is
phase three getting to know Cornell
library colleagues and practices as I
mentioned one of the avenues under
exploration presently is greater
continuity between acquisitions
procedures and practices across the two
libraries however in the near term we're
dealing with two separate sets of
procedures reporting and approval chains
and automated library systems so my
early visits to Cornell involves
spending time with technical services
and processing staff to learn the ropes
at the same time library staff from
Cornell came to New York City to view
our operations and procedures there are
course many differences for
ample Columbia we have an approval plan
with Yankee and harrassowitz for English
and Western European language materials
about my region Weill Cornell uses OCLC
selection I had the opportunity to meet
with the talented frontline reference
desk staff we handle the majority of
undergraduate reference in Queens
including in my area and to discuss how
and when to direct students and faculty
to me phase four develop common approval
profiles and checks and balances based
on our study of the collections and
interviews with faculty we identified
core languages to be collected in common
namely the Baltic languages Belarusian
Bosnian Bulgarian Croatian Czech
Hungarian Macedonian polish romanian
russian serbian slowing in slovak and
ukrainian languages of both historic
strength and current campus interest in
both cases since our goal was to build
collections that are broad and deep and
that do not duplicate one another the
next step was to harmonize approval
vendors across both campuses in some
cases for some languages this was not an
issue as we already were using the same
vendor in others old vendors had to be
replaced and the new common vendor had
to be informed as to what we wanted and
how we proposed it would work we
conveyed the specific details of who
should be notified of the content of
shipments when consolidated financial
reports were due and so forth in essence
the checks and balances needed to inform
columbia and cornell as to what was
coming when and for how much once this
was accomplished we took the data
gathered in phases one and two and
distilled it into a common approval plan
by language each plan had certain common
subject areas with an indication as to
the depth we wish to build this
election on East camp on each campus so
for example we wanted a representation a
representational selection of current
imprints about ecological issues in
Slovenia say while Columbia wanted a
comprehensive collection of the latest
imprints of on Slovenian history
specific areas of more narrow faculty
interest were incorporated as well this
one professor at Cornell whose specialty
is the burgenland Croats or a very small
group within Austria a critical question
we faced was who determines which title
goes where what do we do four areas
Russian literature for example where
there's an intensive faculty interest on
two campuses ultimately this has
required a great leap of faith
thankfully I'm a man of faith one must
feel confident enough in a vendor to
trust them to distribute materials
equitably to both institutions so that
you don't end up with say all 19th
century Russian literature on one campus
in all 20th century on the other it's
like that team-building exercise of
closing your eyes and allowing yourself
to fall backwards sure and the knowledge
of that a colleague will catch you this
act of faith is possible in part because
I have in most cases two decades of
experience with these vendors I know
them personally I visited their
operations in country I regularly
discuss their performance or lack
thereof with library colleagues at other
institutions furthermore monitoring
mechanisms are built into our agreements
I see what Cornell gets electronically
and I get additional feedback from
technical services colleagues in Ithaca
when there's a perceived problem also we
explicitly state in all our
pronouncements to faculty that if you
want something in the collections at
Columbia that was sent to Cornell we
will firm or
it keep in mind that the no duplication
guideline does not pertain to English
language works so the basic tools for
initial discovery by students are
immediately accessible on both campuses
phase 5 allocate acquisitions funding
between columbia and cornell we're
talking about a significant chunk of
change certainly one of the largest
budgets from my area in North America
once i receive budgetary information
from the two administrations i allocate
each institutions fund separately and
inform our vendors the dollar ceilings
for fiscal year shipments to each
institution these figures arrived at in
part on the basis of my experience i
could allocate for example 20,000 and II
didn't each institution for Hungarian
materials but I know that would be
unrealistic based on the publishing
output and per unit pricing of the
Hungarian book market I also keep a
certain amount of my annual allocations
unallocated to provide me with a kind of
flexibility needed to make opportunity
purchases such as rare book or archival
collections or new nuit resources that
come on the market Phase six quid pro
quo costing it all out some elements of
the overall to cool relationship are
purely a matter of aligning policy other
areas such as my own where services are
provided by one of the partners to the
other are governed by formal contracts
so for example Cornell provides Columbia
with cataloguing support for I believe
Turkish language materials on a
contractual basis I confess I kept my
distance from this part of the process
leaving it to the respective a ul's to
to work it out I provide data as to my
likely time input student assistant
staffing needs and so forth and let them
work out the details
finally phase seven communicate
communicate communicate I can't
emphasize enough just how important
communication has been throughout this
process you're asking people faculty
students library colleagues to take
their own leap of faith Cornell faculty
and staff must be comfortable with me as
a professional and not feel that I would
do anything inimical to Cornell's
interests they must know that although
I'm 228 miles away I'm always eager for
their questions and concerns via email
phone or Skype and when I'm in Ithaca
each semester I've I have informed them
ahead of time and seek them out in their
offices the Columbia faculty and my
colleagues and area studies must be
satisfied with the level of attention
given to collections and client l's at
home I regularly send out mass
informational emails to faculty and
students of both institutions and I
issue a to cool newsletter three times a
year highlighting significant
acquisitions and E resources across the
two campuses this has been absolutely
critical for success so after two years
of two cooling for Slavic and east
european studies what are the concrete
achievements in the area of collection
development there has been a dramatic
reduction of duplication rates between
cornell and columbia by way of example
in oclc for russian imprints dated 2008
that is before the implementation of
slavic to cool columbia and cornell had
a 14-percent duplication rate based on
what we spent individually on russian
imprints that year that duplication rate
rate represents about twenty thousand
dollars worth of funds that could have
productively been spent on something
else for 2011 imprints drumroll please
that figure is one point six percent and
there the duplication comes primarily in
the form of non-circulating reference
for hungarian duplication rates went
from four percent to four tenths of one
percent Serbian duplication rates went
down from thirteen percent to zero
percent bottom line collectively were
getting more diverse material into the
hands of researchers than we would have
with the status quo did have been told
to wrap it up in evaluating the success
of the too-cool Slovak public service
model last fall a survey was conducted
among Cornell faculty essentially a
referendum on me and needless to say I
had a few sleepless nights in
anticipation but when the results were
tallied the conclusion was to paraphrase
Sally Field accepting the Oscar for
Norma Rae they really liked me in large
measure and in all humility they were
happy with me because I strive so hard
to keep them informed solicit their
input on new databases and antiquarian
purchases and respond with alacrity to
their requests for reference assistance
or firm order acquisitions I just very
briefly this is maybe a to cool Slovak
is the first World area into the breach
but it is not the last they're my South
Asian colleagues my my Latin American
colleague we're all going to be involved
in our own to cool model and the nice
thing about to cool is that it's not one
size fits all every two cool program is
adapted to the specific needs of the
faculties of the collections and we're
exploring different models for each of
those areas and finally I would say that
it has had a positive impact beyond
cornell and and columbia in that we are
working very closely with for example
our colleagues at Princeton and nypl
to pursue our own kind of mini too cool
for some areas for Polish for example
for check so to cool has been a success
I'm a believer I've dropped the Reverend
Jim school Aid and and and it is having
a positive impact beyond the Ithaca and
NYC so with that you can put away your
cards thank you I'll take questions
whatever yes hello just a quick question
in terms of your catalog if you're
moving really to a one collection model
for these things how does a researcher
at one campus what does the catalog
records show for on shelf for the item
and how is the item access by
researchers at the other campus is it
moved through the interlibrary loan
officer of another way and and where
does it's where does it live when it is
returned does it stay there does it come
back to Columbia reverse ah that is
something that is being worked on by
another committee the idea is that when
you would look at the computer screen
with Cleo if it was available at Cornell
you would see it on screen I believe
we're using borrow direct as the
principal delivery method and that we
still have the the the notion of
ownership so once it was returned you
would go back to to Ithaca I believe but
to be continued I'm just curious in
terms of collection development where
you see a collaborative arrangement with
Cornell that if I understood correctly I
mean I'm just going to choose two fields
out of my head I don't remember the ones
you mentioned that Cornell will collect
all the Ukrainian material and Colombia
will collect all the Belarus material
just how does that work in terms of
people at Cornell who need Belarus
material and don't feel like waiting I
don't know how long it takes I mean that
there's nothing in their library in that
field well that actually it's the
opposite it's shared so we have a common
approval plan you mentioned Ukraine we
have a common approval plan for
Ukrainian materials these are the
subjects in which cornell and columbia
are interested we put it on the vendor
to say okay this is going to Cornell
this is going to call so it's not as if
everything is going to one of the other
it's a different model the same thing
with vendors I mean you may know all the
vendors today but it's quicksand vendors
you know they're you know what do you do
five years from now and you don't know
the vendors so well and putting trust in
people who don't know is well this was
more more the case around 1991-92 where
everything was changing and you had 60
different vendors and they'd be gone the
next day but the vendors were using have
track records that go back a number of
years now so if one goes down there's
there's a range of other vendors that
one could turn to for now just one thing
regarding my own
library which is the Yale library I'm
sure you know tell you mm-hmm just
wondering um yell yell is also in the
vicinity of this greater metropolitan
area closer than Cornell and I'm just
curious it has yell been involved in any
of us we have a fabulous all acclaim but
that you didn't let me get to in this
was it was said that I have also met
with my colleagues my counterparts Tonya
of course Brad shafner at Harvard to
discuss ways in which the three of us
were really the largest collections of
our kind in the East Coast you know
could could do that and also Allen
Hamilton I've been in touch with her as
well so well I'm sorry a Hammond I'm
sorry so we are moving in that direction
thank you very much
now I'd like to invite the speakers from
the Smithsonian Institution up to the
panel and they are Douglas Dunlop David
Kaufman Brian soldo aaron thomas and
mary augusta thomas good it's actually
good afternoon don't worry we are going
to just keep running this as a nice
background of some of you probably have
heard some of us do this kind of thing
before we like pretty pictures where
we're really into pretty pictures so if
you missed it you'll get a chance to see
it again it's just going to keep
flipping I'm Mary Augusta Thomas I'm the
deputy director at Smithsonian libraries
and my pleasure today is to come along
with my colleagues who really do all the
work while they explain how we are
taking our first toddling steps towards
trying to do some knowledge management
with what the Smithsonian knows now on
my way I grabbed the traditional means
of doing a paper a notebook of course
and I'm writing my nose it was a
leftover from a conference we had called
the era of experiments and the age of
wonder this pretty well sums up what's
going on for us the experiments are
constant and the Wonder is wondrous at
times the Smithsonian um how many of you
know of course how many of you have been
here been to the institution all right
so i don't have to quite tell you all
about it um do i just hit that again
Doug come fix this well I keep talking
I'm not even gonna worry about it I
learned years ago you don't do that but
you probably know we have 19 museums the
20th is being built we have 20 libraries
in our system they are all part of one
system they all report centrally they in
fact report mostly to me we have shared
services we have been embedded since the
beginning those 20 libraries are in
about 40 locations that goes from Panama
to New York City and
sort of to Boston historically we are a
very big complex institution technically
we're probably the world's largest
museum complex we're certainly at the
moment the world's largest museum
library when you take all of our
Holdings together and none of this is
organized in any way shape or form that
makes knowledge management and easy
thing to do so for our new academic
model what we're going to try and do is
some basic level work across our system
to share information with each other and
with our museum colleagues we think we
are probably one of the better
organizations at the institution to
tackle this because we are one of the
few that is pan institutional there is a
library as i said in every one of the
museums and research institutes we are
also just by nature learners the whole
institution is the entire institution is
trying to get the word out that we are
constantly engaged in learning among
ourselves and with you and our visitors
and our constituents we're trying to as
the internal phrase has it excite the
learning and everyone not our brand just
our sense of ourselves we support the
research mission of the institution we
want to help people do what they do
better and easier we can just you can
pick these back up and will at some
point we also want to share our SI
knowledge and resources with our outside
constituents we have about the
institution has 30 million visitors a
year the Smithsonian libraries has about
10,000 who come to use our collections
all of our libraries are in fact open to
people to be used and we have millions
more who come to us online it's a very
complex picture so what we're going to
do in our time is Doug Aaron Brian and
David are going to tell you how we took
a small step forward in this within the
last year and give you somewhere where
we're going forward
the reason I'm saying small step is
because the Smithsonian has 137 million
objects 2 million books six hundred
thousand feet of archives etc we do not
have a common vocabulary we are each
Museum and Research Institute exists on
its own as far as its academic work
there are some common administrative
things but in fact pretty much
everyone's a self-defined organization
extraordinarily historical if you
probably know institution goes back
about 160 some years we are going to
have to be creative in how we do this
people do not normally or have not in
the past shared very easily simply
because they have their own interests so
we're coming into an environment where
we are trying to help our colleagues
figure out a few of the ways they can
work together because in our own
strategic plan we want to connect people
we want to collaborate we want to
discover these are all pretty typical
sorts of things we want to share
following on us having a plan and you'll
hear more about that the Smithsonian did
theirs now the Smithsonian wants to
explore the universe they want to
understand biodiversity they want to
value world cultures and they want to
understand the American experience this
is not a small challenge in fact we call
these the four grand challenges this the
really deep challenge here will be for
all of us to work across our more
traditional american history natural
history freer and sackler museum
guidelines panama does tropical research
Marilyn does tropical research they each
do their own so with that I am going to
turn it over to my colleagues to start
telling you more in depth about what we
plan to do in knowledge management my
name is aaron thomas and I'm a digital
librarian at the Smithsonian libraries
and like Mary Augusta was saying service
is really central to everything that we
do
it is it motivates all of our projects
all of our projects are based on you
know improving services or adding an
additional innovative layers to services
so much so the strategic plan that she
mentioned earlier is called focus on
service and it's got um it has you know
features sentences like and the
libraries connect users to people
information and programs the libraries
makes areas of expertise more accessible
the Smithsonian Institution libraries
fosters interdisciplinary research so
it's got words like connecting
discovering building expertise riddled
throughout it and in all of this to us
sort of just read like a blueprint for
knowledge management activities making
it pretty obvious that knowledge
management was a natural area for the
libraries to build our projects around
not to mention that we are also pan
institutional so we had we were one of
the few units within the institution
that had reached to all of the other
players across the institution so we
began thinking about knowledge
management at both the institution and
at the library's thinking about how we
could highlight existing operations
while not creating new layers of
operations you know what just wondering
how we could best improve services while
remaining as unobtrusive as possible the
important points points were that we
were aiming for achievable goals we
needed to create projects that could
improve our services according to the
institution's vision as well as the
library's vision but traditional km or
knowledge management activities were
non-starter we weren't going to spend a
bunch of cash upfront to develop a new
system and then you know tell our
colleagues and staff to start using that
system whenever you know they were
already used to working the way that
they worked so we had to start really
low key really small and really agile
one of the first things we did
at a folklife festival which if you
don't know briefly its a.m. it's a
festival that the Smithsonian puts on
every year on the mall and it highlights
different cultures and last year one of
the one of the different cultures that
was highlighted was the Smithsonian at a
place at a with a theme called the
Smithsonian inside out so that gave an
opportunity for a lot of different
researchers to come and have booths and
to talk about what they were researching
and the libraries thought this was a
really good opportunity for us to you
know go tap on the shoulders and talk to
all of our different colleagues and find
out what they were researching um and we
did we met with you know everyone who
was there they were all really in you
know interested in eager to talk to us
they were all interested in sharing what
they were researching about so we were
able to you know again really small just
collect really small dataset about what
what our colleagues are researching you
know how long they've been at the
Smithsonian just put really simple
questions like that so that was um that
was pretty successful you know so again
knowledge management are the efforts
that you know our knowledge management
efforts again still needs to be really
small but again we were still thinking
about you know how to do more with that
beyond just our one off at the folklife
festival so we started thinking in terms
of a possible internship and that's
gonna talk Thank You Aaron my name is
Doug Dunlop I work in metadata dismiss
mine libraries and first oh we can't
hear me sorry about that
okay I was kind of going to make here
but so first when when we were first
thinking about the internship and what
could accomplish we felt that the
interns could survey information
landscape at the information i'm at the
libraries and throughout the institution
with a fresh set of eyes and they could
give us they could give the time and
focus that were not that we were not
able to devote we also felt the interns
were the internship itself with the chi
bowl as a goal for the library with to
help with the current km our accountant
on knowledge sharing activities with
within the institution if such already
existed we also thought that it was a
more cost-effective way of attacking the
question of knowledge management and
more of a grassroots effort that did not
require a high cost system or a third
party vendor and and additionally we
thought that David and Bryant had helped
with the identification of current
resources within the library and across
the institution that could help everyone
work better without placing another
process into the exist are the existing
system so we did want to add we wanted
to use what was already there we also
wanted to do the internship to provide
as an outcome something that could
demonstrate SI elles ability to connect
information needs and wants and we also
knew that we could not provide the
collaborative tools of libraries
institution needed without first knowing
what everybody was already working on
since it is often the case that two or
more groups are working on similar
projects without knowing what the other
is doing so we wanted to find a way to
resolve this problem and win today and
with that said we initially one desired
outcome of the internship was an overall
km tool for the collection and discovery
of shared areas of interest and
expertise so so as to not how to reduce
our duplicate efforts that already
existed and to connect like-minded
researchers and facilitate more of a
collaborative network
within the libraries and within the
Smithsonian Institution and to achieve
this goal we wanted David and Brian do
survey existing services and knowledge
sharing the vulnerabilities both within
the libraries and also within the
institution we also wanted something
useful for both the libraries and the
institution to show as a proof of
concept we felt that this was a good
goal because collaborative opportunity
these were not fully being taken
advantage of and collaboration was
becoming more important institutionally
as Mary said earlier with grand
challenges we also felt that the project
fit well into the existing SL strategic
plan which included initiative to
position SI l as a center for research
and also to develop a web of SI research
and that fosters interactive research
networks and in order to achieve this we
could we felt that we can help create
and maintain profiles of s IL cuore user
groups and their typical with their
typical characteristics lights and needs
with a focus on known areas of research
now regarding the library's position
within this myth Sounion we felt that
the library was in a good position as an
embedded pan institutional unit to
provide a viable solution and could
harness the institutional see changes
which are putting increased focus on
collaboration we also knew that we had
the tools and resources that are at our
disposal like the Smithsonian research
online and our institutional repository
and additionally we knew that we were
well positioned to work with other units
like the Smithsonian archives the
central information office and the
office of fellowships and interns all of
which in their own way collect and
provide information and in some cases
maintain collection and
management systems and regarding the
outcome of the internship itself
initially we thought we could have a
data set and tool as the outcome
deliverable but that concept quickly
evolved as David and Brian will shortly
discuss we felt that the internship was
the first step towards developing a
knowledge sharing or knowledge
management system for SI l that could
possibly scalp institutionally and with
this in mind the intern project
initially had three stages first survey
the landscape and see what the knowledge
sharing possibilities and potential data
sets si si already has second identify
gaps between the data we currently have
an existing best practices and standards
and finally create specifications that
be used to build a km tool and create a
testbed of data using existing data and
and as you'll find out the internship
itself quickly evolved from that pass
along to david robbins hey I'm Brian
sold oh and this is David Kaufman we we
were the internship team we were both
lis students graduate students at the
time I was at prep Maria I was at the
University of Maryland and basically we
came in and were sort of given this kind
of daunting task of doing two things
which one was to familiarize ourselves
with the institutional culture of the
Smithsonian which is massive and the
knowledge culture that exists there and
to being Elias students um we know about
knowledge and how to handle knowledge
but not necessarily the term knowledge
management which sort of comes out of
corporate culture so we set to really
sitting down and almost writing a
literature review on knowledge
management what it's been what it has
the potential to be what has worked and
what has not worked at other
institutions yeah so as we explore the
topic of knowledge management actually I
think Aaron later on is going to talk
about how
disqus knowledge management with people
in the organization you might not want
to use the term knowledge management
excuse me so knowledge management became
popular in the 90s as corporate managers
became concerned about getting
efficiency from their knowledge workers
in their knowledge economy and people
were concerned with questions like you
know how do we know what we know and how
can we make sure that everyone knows
what they need to know and so that
billions of dollars were spent on
complex document management systems that
imposed work processes on employees had
no incentive to participate because what
makes us you know valuable and unique is
often what we know that other people
don't know and so the ideas that people
would you know would file reports and
dump knowledge into you know vast
repositories and somehow through magic
everyone would have the same vocabulary
and know where everything was going and
actually use this system and then I can
actually put stuff into it and then know
what's in it and as librarians know
people don't always classify information
in the same ways noodle says say
customers were dissatisfied and money
and time were wasted and knowledge
management has I'd say evolved it's now
more focused on culture management and
leadership and getting workers to value
and pursue sharing and in fact at IBM
where it's a big deal that term
knowledge management has been cast aside
in favor of knowledge sharing and now it
focuses more on communication and
collaboration tools such as special
social media tools for corporations or
enterprise two point oh you know like a
facebook for for corporations and
chatter and Yammer or examples of
products that sometimes people use and
so it's sort of like knowledge on demand
like you don't need to know where the
information we need to know where the
person has the information is where you
need to put out a request for
information and and the person that has
it will will answer it for you and so
those are you know the dominant sort of
areas for knowledge management and we
rejected those for the Smithsonian
Institution libraries those are culture
changing endeavors and though that the
library is paying institutional
we didn't feel that it could has the
it's mal position to influence how
people work minute to minute in that way
so we put those aside so what we did
come up with and we we came up with
basically two suggestions for the baby
steps the you know the cornerstone in
building a foundation for knowledge
management system which of course was
not to be called a knowledge management
system and one of the biggest problem
that we identified is the eye and from
the strategic plan is this idea of
expertise location the fact that there
are so many disparate units and the
institution is so large we wanted to
make it easier for people to find the
expertise that they were looking for the
grand challenges are interdisciplinary
and they come with grant money so
there's there's an incentive for people
in different museums and research
centers to collaborate on an
interdisciplinary project but in order
to do that in order to facilitate that
you need to be able to find people that
maybe can work on similar ideas so we
looked at again enterprise solutions but
that was kind of not really possible so
we wanted to look at what was possible
within the existing cyber infrastructure
at Smithsonian within the existing
culture and we learned by talking to
ocio which is the IT unit at Smithsonian
that they were rolling out a new staff
directory that had the capability to
include expertise unfortunately ocio
wanted people to just populate their own
and mostly most people are not going to
do that so we actually sat down and
talked to them about creating a taxonomy
of expertise and expertise can go
anywhere from you know the research
level to the paraprofessional level to
the administration administrative level
you know who who's good at booking
conference rooms stuff like that
so we basically suggested that still
take the lead in creating a taxonomy of
expertise that would be pre-populated as
an employee came in in in the staff
directory create a real robust staff
directory and that they coordinate the
project investigate units and lists of
expertise some units already had
taxonomy use of expertise and compile
working John titles these are federal
jobs so the your job as it exists at the
federal level is not necessarily what
your job is like in the HR the HR
database will say something describe you
in a way that has nothing to do with
what you do so the ultimate goal being a
taxonomy of expertise within the staff
directory and we also also took a look
at org charts David compiled there's a
massive war chart of how the Smithsonian
is structured and then it goes down and
down and down to the unit level to the
subunit level so we there's no real map
of that there's no real map of the
structure of the institution it was an
imaginary org chart yeah we made it so
what we did was we created a sort of
interactive one where you could actually
click into each square of each unit and
then click click click down to kind of
get up where get a real visual of how
the how the organization really really
functions and who the person you would
go to is and that's something that we
suggested be maintained and updated as
people as the organizational structure
changes and as people move in and out of
jobs that was based on interviews with
people who were new and they described
they just could not understand where
they were at all the yeah but we were
continually told was that it takes two
years for you a new employee to really
get
sense of the institution yes I couldn't
test that I'm in my third year at the
institution I can attest to that and see
if now mastered it should I go on to the
next area so the other area of knowledge
management that we that we decided that
the SI l should pursue his knowledge
retention which has become prominent in
some organizations thanks to concern
about the brain drain caused by sort of
massive retiring of the baby boomer
generation and which is a a situation
that it's also being confronted that the
Smithsonian is also confronting and so
an example of an organization that
prioritizes knowledge retention is that
power company the Tennessee Valley
Authority they have a huge complex and
critical infrastructure it's managed by
an aging workforce so they wanted to
know you know is are we going to not
know how to turn these you know tomorrow
some was going to retire now know how to
fix something you know turn something on
so they started by creating a created a
calculated risk calculation for
knowledge they measured how important
certain knowledge was and how likely it
was that the person who has it is going
to is going to retire soon and so they
figured out how how they could order who
to interview and they looked at ways of
organizing that information so we
interview to retiring knowledge workers
at some sony and a librarian and a
researcher to test that process and to
try to assess their risk and disco we
discuss their work processes and we
uncovered several areas for both folks
who were a you know unique knowledge
they were in the sole possession of and
they hadn't really considered how that
information that knowledge might be
retained after after they had left so so
we decided that maybe this was an area
that Smithsonian should pursue in it but
it's also not something you can just
sort of know someone's thinking about
retiring we've got a couple months left
let's start you know writing doubts
following them around and scribbling
stuff down
it's a it's about having a collaborative
work environment and having people on
you know value sharing with each other
so that it's redundancy oh there's an
understanding what each other is doing
and then also but it also can be
formalized more seriously because it's
important because people you know you
can take it with you Doug's gonna go
it's good in eretz well you know there's
not much to wrap up is this was I think
a very successful internship for sure um
it one of the results was a paper that
was written sort of outlining key places
to continue to investigate and those
were the knowledge knowledge retention
in that sort of his location and the
probably yard we're continuing you know
with projects in those tasks the
libraries and and the institution are
definitely collaboration centered and
the libraries are continue to seek out
ways in which we can bring you know
bring our unique expertise to other
collaborations like I think that there
was a quote i read recently from the
secretary that said something about the
ideal collaboration being you know two
partners that provide something that the
other cannot and i think what the
libraries has to offer is definitely
something that other partners will
definitely you know benefit from again i
might add that these are projects that
also require collaboration where the IT
department with right right rangeman
resources department so and you know
they're about collaboration but they
require as well questions including
that's a fire pit if you were wondering
what that circle of sand is it's in the
National Museum of American Indian
questions a hand up over here there's
one there
one of my questions is it sounds like
much of what you've dealt with has to do
not all that operational expertise did
you look at the published I know that
the reefs the Institute's have
researchers just like NIH or any other
academic institution did you want a
major tap into their bibliographies
their publications and and out of
standard databases and be able to
resolve identity and those issues um we
didn't mention well we mentioned very
briefly something called Smithsonian
research online that's actually the
official bibliography of the research of
the institution all pretty much it's
intended to be all the published papers
of the Smithsonian staff now the
library's runs that we are responsible
for that project we've been doing that
for a couple of years now so we do have
in a sense some hold on the bibliography
of the work that's being done the
published work that's being done and it
is a requirement if you're going for
your peer review which the scientists
and researchers all do go through and
the historians that you have contributed
your work to the bibliography if you're
not in the SRO it doesn't exist so that
does give us the level of the
professional achievement what we don't
know because people publish perhaps in a
lot in a very select area is what
they're also doing on the side so the
guy who is in fishes who is an expert on
truffles and the person who is in music
in american indian museum because
they're looking at particular tribal
music who may also be a musician who
could contribute to music throughout the
institution it's that much more
interdisciplinary level that's hard to
identify people self-identify in most
cases even in their publishing so they
might be in fact in two or three
scientific areas they might actually all
so be in history art and culture or
search science history art and culture
you I'm just these are just some of the
contacts and some of the sites I think
that we also control at the moment or
try to control the digital repository
for the institution that went in fact
from nothing to almost 20,000 articles
in the last four years that requires us
going out and really working with people
because there never was a requirement
that you make a digital version of your
material accessible now these are the
printed on the science data side there
is no coordinated effort it is only
beginning now people keep their data
their scientific data in every form
imaginable I mean people who go for big
grants obviously have to file data
management people who don't go for
grants and not everyone has to in our
environment may have it in their
computer and it might be in their
computer at home and I've had senior
scientists show me their file drawers of
years of data so that's an area the
institution's only now tackling but our
questions are more this
cross-disciplinary or more informal
collaboration so I'll give you an idea
of some of the Grand Challenge projects
that were mentioned music turns out of
course there's music in every part of
the institution but people rarely had a
chance to talk to each other immigration
immigration isn't just about what
American history does on the subject I
mean there's a lot plastics one of my
favorite goes clear across the
institution the cooper-hewitt here in
New York I'm is very involved because
plastics are in the collection plastic
conservation the study of plastics what
else and then there's the big science
topics so we have one more over here
right two more how is this initiative
also impacted by public access
collaboration like the Smithsonian
Commons
well we're going to try and work with
them I mean certainly we do oh did you
guys talk to my kids in or the comments
no no there was something that we were
we were thinking about we know that's
out there I guess it needs to be as a
concept for the developed before we can
release that in it and there are some
existing things we can do with use of
SharePoint or with our in-house prism
and and also we're looking into stuff
like research or ID so there you know
but as far as within that kind of the
common thing that hasn't really been I
don't like a really adapted across
institutions and then here um please so
I was glad to hear you mention the
repository and excited to hear it's
growing so quickly I was curious my
understanding is that an initiative
that's going on now is to actually
leverage the repository to sort of have
an active workspace for researchers for
their research data and projects and I
was curious if that's presenting an
opportunity sort of have that you know
collaboration awareness and
discoverability of people's you know
where they're doing their work to help
encourage that I have you speaking of a
Smithsonian initiative in this area or
the government research yes thorny
staples don't do something that's that's
what we needed was the name yes
definitely and thorny is important to
what we're doing and I hope at some
point will be important to him this is
as a central office of the chief
information officer and it is this
project as I mentioned is there's been
no standard way of sharing data he is
looking at two things right now he's at
the stage of a system to help
researchers who are applying for grants
know how to answer the data management
requests and then they are looking at
ways to share data and I believe you
spoke with him yeah I'm basically we
that was actually my first idea was to
do something with the repository and
somehow
link up with the repository but
basically in the meetings that we had it
was just too early in in both to it was
too early to collaborate in both
initiatives to really get something
started now so it's it I think that
that's definitely something that's
that's been brought up but it's and it's
a next step or a third step kind of
thing well we are talking to thorny
about a repository and having that may
be migrated into that environment or at
least be able to work better with that
environment so we're currently using
difficulties in deep space and we're
going to look into using Drupal there's
anything of that nature so that data can
be shared more easily with that you've
been very patient here I think we have
to take the one more and then we can
wrap work with the NARC just fascinated
by what the 20 is students did and I
really held out to just comment how very
very important what you did it must
accomplish for your institution but also
for the profession and I hope that you
make your findings of public up and in a
way that will help us across disciplines
because this is where it is at whether
you're a library or a research
institution to have a robust membership
directory and to have now implement
knowledge sharing is critical in today's
world in the 21st century and thank you
for sharing your the class worth coming
you